all right welcome everyone to the first
reading uh I'm going to be doing this
with a number of short stories and so
this is Story Time with Gregory Sadler I
am Gregory Sadler I think those of you
who are tuning in already know me and
I've decided to do some live readings of
some of my favorite short stories some
people asked if I would do novels and I
I think that might be a little bit
longish and there's a lot of short
stories that I can talk about
and so I'll tell you a little bit about
the short story that we're going to
start with here cord weiner Smith the
game of rat and dragon and why I like it
so much and then I'm just going to read
the story as best as I can and you know
you're welcome to say things in the live
chat I'll respond to questions and
comments after the reading and I'll keep
this relatively short so we can jump
right in this is a story that I read
back in my childhood and like a lot of
stories that I got introduced to it was
through the intermediary of my great
uncle Hubert who was a
bibliophile self-educated person very
interested in science fiction and this
was in some science fiction Anthology
that I was
um I got my hands on and I was reading
my way through at the time and I don't
know which anthology
it was but this story so impressed
itself upon me
even as a child and every time that I
came back to it to reread it it has a
sort of freshness to it and it gained
additional depth and as many of you know
I had a cat companion named sassy who I
became very close to who died last year
19 years old
and uh I would you know as I would
reread this I would think sometimes of
the very close relationship between
myself and sassy and I could imagine you
know myself in these sorts of positions
as you'll see if you're not familiar
with the story it is a science fiction
story about what's happening largely in
deep space as humankind is expanding
outward to the Stars uh cord weiner
Smith uh very interesting author that's
actually a pseudonym for him because he
was in his day job a U.S military
analyst and you know professor and all
these other things he's also from here
in Milwaukee originally although he
didn't really spend much time here so
that's probably enough about the story
at the beginning I'm sure we'll have
some great discussion as time goes on
and I'm just going to launch right into
the reading and we'll see how long it
takes us
so the game of rat and dragon number one
the table
pin lighting is a hell of a way to earn
a living Underhill was Furious as he
closed the door behind himself it didn't
make much sense to wear a uniform and
look like a soldier if people didn't
appreciate what you did
he sat down in his chair laid his head
back in the headrest and pulled the
helmet down over his forehead as he
waited for the pin set to warm up he
remembered the girl in the outer
Corridor she'd looked at it and then
looked at him scornfully meow that was
all she had said yet it had cut him like
a knife
what did she think he was a fool a
loafer a uniform non-entity didn't she
know that for every half hour of pin
lighting he got a minimum of two months
recuperation at the hospital
by now the set was warm he felt the
squares of space around him sensed
himself at the middle of an immense grid
a cubic grid full of nothing out in that
nothingness he could sense the hollow
aching horror of space itself and could
feel the terrible anxiety which his mind
encountered whenever it meant the
faintest trace of a nerd dust
as he relaxed the comforting solidity of
the Sun the Clockwork of the familiar
planets and the moon rang in on him our
own solar system was as charming and
simple as an ancient cuckoo clock filled
with familiar ticking and reassuring
noises the odd little moons of Mars
swung around their Planet like frantic
mice yet their regularity was itself an
assurance that all was well
far above the plane of the elliptic he
could feel half a ton of dust more or
less drifting outside the lanes of human
travel here there was nothing to fight
nothing to challenge the mind to tear
the living soul out of the body with its
roots dripping and effluvium as tangible
as blood nothing ever moved in the solar
system he could wear the pin set forever
and be nothing more than just a sort of
telepathic astronomer
a man who could feel the hot warm
protection of the sun throbbing and
burning against his living mind
Woodley came in
same old ticking World said Underhill
nothing to report no wonder they didn't
develop the pin set until they began to
plan a form down here with the hot sun
around us it feels so good and so quiet
you can feel everything spinning and
turning it's nice and sharp and compact
it's sort of like sitting around home
Woodly grunted he was not much given to
flights of fantasy
undeterred Underhill went on it must
have been pretty good to have been an
ancient man I wonder why they burned up
their world with war they didn't have to
play in a form they didn't have to go
out to earn their livings Among the
Stars they didn't have to dodge the rats
or play the game they couldn't have
invented pin lighting because they
didn't have any need of it did they
would they would leave grunted Woodley
was 26 years old and due to retire in
one more year he already had a farm
picked out he had gotten through 10
years of hard work pin lighting with the
best of them he'd kept his sanity by not
thinking very much about his job meeting
the strains of the task whenever he had
to meet them and thinking nothing more
about his duties until the next
emergency arose Woodley never made a
point of getting popular among the
partners none of the partners liked him
very much some of them even resented him
he was suspected of thinking ugly
thoughts of the partners on occasion but
since none of the partners ever thought
a complaint in articulate form the other
pin lighters and the chiefs of the
instrumentality left him alone
Underhill was still full of The Wonder
of their job
happily he babbled on what does happen
to us when we plan a form do you think
it's a sort of like dying do you ever
see anybody who had his soul pulled out
pulling Souls is just a way of talking
about it said Woodley after all these
years no one knows whether we have souls
or not
but I saw one once I saw what dog would
look like when he came apart there was
something funny it looked wet and sort
of sticky as if it were bleeding and it
went out of him and you know what they
did to Dogwood they took him away up in
that part of the hospital where you and
I never go way up at the top part where
the others are where the others always
have to go if they're alive after the
Rats of the up and out have gotten them
Woodley sat down and lit an ancient pipe
he was burning something called tobacco
in it it was a dirty sort of habit but
it made him look very dashing and
adventurous
look here youngster you don't have to
worry about that stuff pin lighting is
getting better all the time the partners
are getting better I've seen them pin
light two rats 46 million miles apart
and one and a half milliseconds as long
as people had to try to work the pin
sets themselves there was always the
chance that with a minimum of 400
milliseconds for the human mind to set
up a pin light we wouldn't light the
rats up fast enough to protect our
planet forming ships the partners have
changed all that once they get going
they're faster than rats and they will
always be I know it's not easy letting a
partner share your mind
it's not easy for them either said
Underhill
don't worry about them they're not human
let them take care of themselves I've
seen more pin lighters go crazy from
monkeying around with Partners than I've
ever seen caught by the rats how many of
them do you actually know that got
grabbed by rats Underhill looked down at
his fingers which Shone green and purple
and the Vivid light thrown by the tuned
in pin set and counted ships
the thumb for the Andromeda lost with
crew and passengers the index finger and
the middle finger for release ships 43
and 56 found with their pin sets burned
out and every man woman and child on
board dead or insane the ring finger the
little finger and the thumb of the other
hand were the first three battleships to
be lost to the rats lost as people
realized that there was something out
there underneath space itself which was
a live capricious and malevolent
platforming was sort of funny it felt
like like nothing much like the twinge
of a mild electric shock like the ache
of a sore tooth Bitten on for the first
time like a slightly painful flash of
light against the eyes
yet in that time of forty thousand ton
ship lifting free above Earth
disappeared somehow or another into two
dimensions and appeared half a light
year or 50 light years off
at one moment he would be sitting in the
fighting room the pin set ready and the
familiar solar system ticking around
inside his head for a second or a year
he could never tell how long it really
was subjectively the funny little flash
went through him and then he was loose
in the up and out the terrible open
spaces between the Stars where the stars
themselves felt like pimples on his
telepathic mind and the planets were too
far away to be sensed or red
somewhere in this outer space a gruesome
death awaited death and horror of a Kind
which man had never encountered until he
reached out for Interstellar space
itself apparently the light of the Suns
kept the dragons away
dragons that's what people call them
to Ordinary People there was nothing
nothing except the shiver of
planetforming and the hammer blow of
sudden death or the dark note of
lunacy descending into their minds
but to the telepaths they were dragons
in the fraction of a second between the
telepath's awareness of the Hostile
something out in the black Hollow
nothingness of space and the impact of a
ferocious ruinous psychic blow against
all the living things within the ship
the telepaths had sensed entities
something like the dragons of ancient
human lore beasts more clever than
beasts demons more tangible than demons
hungry vortices of aliveness and the
hate compounded by unknown means out of
the thin tenuous matter between Stars
it took a surviving ship to bring back
the news a ship in which by sheer chance
a telepath had a light beam ready to
turning it out at the innocent dust so
that within the Panorama of his mind the
dragon dissolved into nothing at all and
the other passengers themselves
non-telepathic went about their way not
realizing that their own immediate
deaths had been averted from then on it
was easy almost
platforming ships always carry telepaths
telepaths had their sensitiveness
enlarged to an immense range by the pin
sets which were telepathic amplifiers
adapted to the mammal mind the pin sets
in turn were electronically geared into
small dirigible light bombs light did it
light broke up the dragons
allowed the ships to reform
three-dimensionally skip skip as they
moved from star to star the odd suddenly
moved down from 100 to one against
mankind to 60 to 40 in Mankind's favor
this is not enough
the telepaths were trained to become
Ultra sensitive trained to become aware
of dragons in less than a millisecond
but it was found the dragons could move
a million miles in just under two
milliseconds and this was not enough for
the human mind to activate the light
beams
attempts have been made to sheath the
ships in light at all times that defense
wore out as mankind learned about the
dragon so too apparently the dragons
learned about Mankind somehow they
flattened their own Balkan came in on
extremely flat trajectories very quickly
and tense light was needed light of
sun-like intensity this could be
provided only by light bombs pin
lighting came into existence
pin lighting consisted in the detonation
of ultra Vivid miniature photonuclear
bombs which converted a few ounces of a
magnesium isotope into pure visible
Radiance the odds kept coming down in
Mankind's favor yet ships were being
lost
it became so bad that people didn't even
want to find the ships
because The Rescuers knew what they
would see it was sad to bring back to
Earth 300 bodies ready for burial and
200 or 300 lunatics damage Beyond repair
to be awakened and fed and cleaned and
put to sleep awakened and fed again
until their lives were ended
telepaths tried to reach into the minds
of the psychotics who'd been damaged by
the dragons but they found nothing there
Beyond Vivid spouting Columns of fiery
Terror bursting from the primordial it
itself the volcanic source of life
and then came the partners man and
partner could do together what man could
not do alone
men had the intellect Partners the speed
the partners rode in their tiny craft no
larger than footballs outside the
spaceships they plan a formed with the
ships they rode beside them in their
six-pound craft ready to attack the tiny
ships of the partners were Swift each
carried a dozen pin lights bombs no
bigger than Thimbles the pin lighters
through the partners quite literally
through by means of Mind firing relays
directly at the dragons
what seemed to be dragons to the human
mind appeared in the form of gigantic
rats in the minds of the partners out in
the pitiless nothingness of space the
partner's Minds responded to an instinct
as old as life the partners attacked
striking with a speed faster than man's
going from Attack to attack until the
rats or themselves were destroyed almost
all the time it was the partners who won
with the safety of the interstellar skip
skip of the ships Commerce increased
immensely the population of all the
colonies went up and the demand for
trained Partners increased
Underhill and Woodley were part of the
third generation of pin lighters and yet
to them it seemed as though their craft
had endured forever
gearing space into mines by means of the
pin set adding the partners to those
Minds keying up the mines for the
tension of a fight on which all demanded
this is more than human synapses could
stand for long Underhill needed his
two-month rest after half an hour of
fighting Woodley needed his retirement
after 10 years of service they were
young they were good
but they had limitations
so much depended on the choice of
Partners so much on the sheer luck of
who drew whom
part two
the shuffle
father Moon tree and the little girl
named West entered the room they were
the other two pin lighters the human
compliment of the fighting room was now
complete
father Moon tree was a red-faced man of
45 who lived the peaceful life of a
farmer until he reached his 40th year
only then belatedly did the authorities
find he was telepathic and agree to let
him late in life enter upon the career
of pin lighter he did well at it but he
was fantastically old for this kind of
business father Moon tree looked at the
glum Woodley in the musing Underhill how
are the youngsters today ready for a
good fight
father always wants a fight giggled the
little girl named West she was such a
little little girl her Giggle was high
and childish she looked like the last
person in the world one would expect to
find in the rough sharp dueling of pin
lighting Underhill had been amused one
time when he'd found one of the most
sluggish of the partners coming away
Happy from contact with the mind of the
girl named West usually the partners
didn't care much about the human Minds
with which they repaired for the journey
the partners seemed to take the attitude
that the human Minds were complex and
followed up beyond belief anyhow no
partner ever questioned the superiority
of the human mind though very few of the
partners were much impressed by that
superiority the partners liked people
they were willing to fight with them
they were even willing to die for them
but when a partner liked an individual
the way for example that Captain wah or
the lady May liked Underhill the liking
had nothing to do with intellect it was
a matter of temperament of feel
Underhill knew perfectly well that
Captain Wahl regarded his underhills
brains as silly well Captain wow liked
was underhill's friendly emotional
structure the cheerfulness and glint of
wicked Amusement that shot through
underhill's unconscious thought patterns
and the gaiety with which Underhill
faced Danger The Words the history books
the ideas the science Underhill could
sense all that in his own mind reflected
back from Captain Wild's mind is so much
rubbish
Miss West looked at Underhill I bet you
put stems on the stones I did not
Underhill felt his ears grow red with
embarrassment during his novitiate he'd
tried to cheat in the lottery because he
got particularly fond of a special
partner a lovely young mother named
myrrh it was so much easier to operate
with merge she was so affectionate
towards him that he forgot PIN lighting
was hard work and that he was not
instructed to have a good time with his
partner they were both designed and
prepared to go into deadly battle
together
one cheating had been enough they'd
found him out and he'd been laughed at
for years father Moon tree picked up the
imitation leather cup and shook the
stone dice which assigned them their
partners for the ship by senior rights
he took first draw he grimaced he'd
drawn a greedy old character a tuffled
male whose mind was full of slobbering
thoughts of food veritable oceans full
of half-spoiled fish father Moon trade
once said he burped cod liver oil for
weeks after drawing that particular
Glutton so strongly had the telepathic
image of fish impressed itself on his
mind yet the Glutton was a glutton for
danger as well as for fish he had killed
63 dragons more than any other partner
in the service and was quite literally
worth his weight in gold
the little girl West came next she Drew
Captain wow when she saw who it was she
smiled I like him she said he's such fun
to fight with he feels so nice and
cuddly in his in my mind
cuddly hell said Woodley I've been in
his mind too it's the most leering mind
in this bar none nasty man said the
little girl she said it declaratively
without reproach Underhill looking at
her shivered
he didn't see how she could take Captain
while so calmly Captain Wow's mind did
leer when Captain wow got excited in the
middle of a battle confused images of
dragons deadly rats luscious beds the
smell of fish and the shock of space all
scrambled together in his mind as as he
and Captain while their Consciousness is
linked together through the pin set
became a fantastic composite of human
being and Persian cat
that's the trouble with working with
cats thought Underhill it's a Pity that
no nothing else will serve as partner
cats were all right once you got in
touch with them telepathically they were
smart enough to meet the needs of the
fight but their motives and desires were
certainly different from those of humans
they were companionable enough so long
as you thought tangible images at them
but their minds just closed up and went
to sleep when you recited Shakespeare or
Coal Grove or if you tried to tell them
what space was
it was sort of funny realizing the
partners who were so grim and mature out
here in space were the same cute little
animals that people had used as pets for
thousands of years back on Earth he had
embarrassed himself more than once while
on the ground saluting perfectly
ordinary non-telepathic cats because
he'd forgotten for the moment they were
not partners
he picked up the cup and shook out his
Stone dice he was lucky
he drew the lady May
the lady May was the most thoughtful
partner he had ever met in her the
finely bred pedigree of a Persian cat
had reached one of its highest peaks of
development she was more complex than
any human woman but the complexity was
all one of emotions memory hope and
discriminated experience experience
sorted through without benefit of words
when he had first come in contact with
her mind he was astonished at its
Clarity with her he remembered her
kitten Hood he remembered every mating
experience she'd ever had he saw in a
half recognizable Gallery all the other
pin lighters with whom she'd been paired
for the fight and he saw himself radiant
cheerful and desirable
he even thought he caught the edge of a
longing a very flattering and yearning
thought
what a Pity he is not a cat
Woodley picked up the last Stone he drew
what he deserved a sullen scare scarred
old Tomcat with none of the Verve of
Captain wow Woodley's partner was one of
the most animal of the cats on the ship
although brutish type with a dull mine
even telepathy had not refined his
character his ears were half chewed off
from the first fights in which he'd
engage he was a serviceable fighter
nothing more Woodly grunted Underhill
glands denim oddly didn't Woodley do
ever do anything but grunt
father Moon tree looked at the other
three you might as well get your
partners out I'll let the go Captain
know we're ready to go into the up and
out
part three
the deal
Underhill spun the combination lock on
the ladies maze cage he walked her
gently and took her into his arms she
humped her back luxuriously stretched
her claws started to purr thought better
of it and licked him on the wrist
instead he did not have the pin set on
so their mines were closed to each other
but in the angle of her mustache and the
movement of her ears he caught some
sense of the gratification she
experienced in finding him as her
partner he talked to her in human speech
even though speech meant nothing to a
cat when the pin set was not on
it's a damn shame sending a sweet little
thing like you whirling around in the
coldness of nothing to hunt for rats
that are bigger and deadlier than all of
us put together you didn't ask for this
sort of fight did you
for answer she licked his hand purd
tickled his cheek with her long fluffy
tail turned around and faced him golden
eyes Shining
for a moment they stared at each other
man squatting cat standing erect on her
hind legs front claws digging into his
knee human eyes and cat eyes looked
across an immensity which no words could
meet but which affection spanned in a
single glance
time to get in he said
she walked osely to her spheroid carrier
she climbed in he saw to it that her
Miniature Pin set rested firmly and
comfortably against the base of her
brain he made sure that her claws were
padded so she could not tear herself in
the excitement of battle
softly he said to her ready
for answer she preened her back as much
as her harness would permit and Purge
softly within the confines of the frame
that held her he slapped down the lid
and watched the sealant ooze around the
seam for a few hours she was welded into
her projectile into a Workman with a
short cutting Arc would remove her after
she'd done her Duty
he picked up the entire projectile and
slipped it into the ejection tube he
closed the door of the tube spun the
lock seated himself in his chair and put
his own pin set on
once again he flung The Switch
he sat in a small room small small warm
warm the bodies of the other three
people moving close around him the
tangible lights and the ceiling bright
and heavy against his closed eyelids as
the pin set warmed the room fell away
the other people ceased to be people and
became small glowing heaps of fire
embers Dark red fire with the
consciousness of Life burning like old
red coals in a Country Fireplace
as the pin set warmed a little more he
felt Earth just below him felt the ship
slipping away felt the Turning Moon as
it swung on the far side of the world
felt the planets and the hot clear
goodness of the sun which kept the
dragons so far for Mankind's native
ground finally he reached complete
awareness
he was telepic telepathically alive to a
range of millions of miles
he felt the dust which he had noticed
earlier high above the elliptic with a
thrill of warmth and tenderness he felt
the consciousness of the lady May
pouring over into his own
her Consciousness was as gentle and
clear and yet sharp to the taste of the
Mind as if it were scented oil
it felt reassuring and relaxing he could
sense her welcome of him
it was scarcely a thought just a raw
emotion of greeting
at last they were one again
in a tiny remote corner of his mind as
Tiny as the smallest toy he'd ever seen
in his childhood he was still aware of
the room and the ship in a father Moon
tree picking up a telephone and speaking
to a go captain in charge of the ship
his telepathic mind caught the idea long
before his ears could frame the words
the actual sound followed the idea the
way the thunder on an ocean beach
follows the lightning inward from far
out over the seas
the fighting room is ready clear to
platform sir
part four the play
Underhill was always a little
exasperated the way that lady may
experience things before he did he was
braced for the quick vinegar thrill of
playing a farming but he caught her
report of it before his own nerves could
register what happened Earth had fallen
so far away he groped for several
milliseconds before he found the sun in
the upper rear right-hand corner of his
telepathic mind
that was a good jump he thought this way
we'll get there in four or five skips
a few hundred miles outside the ship the
lady May thought back at him oh warm oh
generous oh gigantic man oh Brave oh
friendly oh tender and huge partner oh
wonderful with you with you so good good
good warm warm now to fight now to go
good with you
he knew she was not thinking words that
his mind took the clear amiable Babble
of her cat intellect and translated it
into images which his own thinking could
record and understand
neither one of them was absorbed in the
game of mutual greetings he reached out
far beyond her range of perception to
see if there was anything near the ship
it was funny how it was possible to do
two things at once he could scan space
with his pin set mind and yet at the
same time catch a vagrant thought of
hers a lovely affectionate thought about
a son who had had a golden face and a
chest covered with soft incredibly Downy
white fur
while he was still searching he caught
the warning from her we jump again
and so they had the ship had moved on to
a second platform the stars were
different
the sun was immeasurably far behind even
the nearest stars were barely in contact
this is good Dragon country this open
nasty Hollow kind of space he reached
farther faster sensing and looking for
danger ready to fling the lady May at
danger wherever he found it
Terror blazed up in his mind so clear so
sharp that it came through as a physical
wrench the little girl named West had
found something something immense long
black sharp greedy horrific she flung
Captain wow at it Underhill tried to
keep his own mind clear watch out he
shouted telepathically at the others
trying to move the lady May around at
one corner of the battle he felt the
lustful Rage of Captain wow as the big
Persian Tomcat detonated lights while he
approached the streak of dust which
threatened the ship and the people
within the lights scored near misses the
dust flattened itself changing from the
shape of a stingray into the shape of a
spear not three milliseconds had a lot
elapsed father Moon tree was talking
human words and was saying in a voice
that moved like cold molasses out of a
heavy jar
kept
Underhill knew the sentence was going to
be Captain move fast the battle would be
fought and finished before father Moon
tree got through talking
now fractions of a millisecond later
lady May was directly in line here was
where the skill and the speed of the
Partners came in she could react faster
than he she could see the threat as an
immense rat coming directly at her she
could fire the light bombs with the
Discrimination which he might miss he
was connected with her mind but he could
not follow it
his Consciousness absorbed the tearing
wound inflicted by the alien enemy it
was like no wound on Earth raw crazy
pain which started like a burn in his
navel he began to writhe in his chair
actually he'd not yet had time to move a
muscle when the lady May struck back at
their enemy five evenly placed
photonuclear bombs blazed across a
hundred thousand miles the pain in his
body and mind vanished
he felt a moment of fierce terrible
feral Elation running through the mind
of the lady may as she finished her kill
it was always disappointing to the cats
to find out that their enemies
disappeared at the moment of Destruction
then he felt her hurt
the pain and the fear that swept over
both of them as the battle quicker than
the movement of an eyelid had come and
gone in the same instant there came the
sharp and acid twinge of platiform once
more the ship went skip
he could hear Woodly thinking at him you
don't have to bother much this old son
of a gun and I will take over for a
while twice again the twinge the skip
he had no idea where he was until the
lights of the Caledonia Spaceport shown
below
with a weariness that lay almost beyond
the limits of thought he threw his mind
back into the rapport with the pin set
fixing the lady maze projectile gently
and neatly in its launching tube she was
half dead with fatigue but he could feel
the beat of her heart and listen to her
panting and he grasped The Grateful edge
of a thanks reaching from her mind to
his
five the score
they put him into the hospital at
Caledonia the doctor was friendly but
firm
you actually got touched by that Dragon
that's as close a shave as I've ever
seen it's also quick that it'll be a
long time before we know what happened
scientifically but I suppose you'd be
ready for the insane asylum now if the
contact had lasted several tenths of a
millisecond later what kind of cat did
you have out in front of you
Underhill
felt the words coming out of him slowly
words were such a lot of trouble
compared to the speed and joy of
thinking fast and sharp and clear mind
to mind but words were all that could
reach ordinary people like this doctor
his mouth moved heavily as he
articulated words
don't call our partners cats the right
thing to call them is Partners they
fight for us in a team you ought to know
that we call them Partners not cats how
is mine
I don't know said the doctor contritely
we'll we'll find out for you meanwhile
old man you take it easy there's nothing
but rest that can help you can you make
yourself sleep or would you like us to
give you some kind of sedative
I can sleep said Underhill I just want
to know about the lady May
the nurse joined in she was a little
antagonistic
don't you want to know about the other
people
they're okay said Underhill I knew that
before I came in here he stretches arms
inside and grinned at them
he could see they were relaxing and
beginning to treat him as a person
instead of the patient
I'm all right he said just let me know
when I can go see my partner a new
thought struck him he looked wildly at
the doctor they didn't send her off at
the ship did they
all find out right away so the doctor he
gave Underhill a reassuring squeeze of
the shoulder and left the room the nurse
took a napkin off a goblet of chilled
fruit juice Underhill tried to smile at
her there seemed to be something wrong
with the girl he wished she would go
away first she'd started to be friendly
now she was distant again
it's a nuisance being telepathic he
thought you keep trying to reach even
when you're not making contact
suddenly she swung around on him you pin
lighters you and your damn cats just as
she Stamped Out he burst into her mind
he saw himself a radiant hero clad and
his smooth suede uniform the pin set
Crown shining like ancient Jewels around
his head he saw his own face handsome
and masculine shining out of her mind he
saw himself very far away and saw
himself as she hated him she hated him
in the secrecy of her own mind she hated
him because he was she thought proud and
strange and Rich better and more
beautiful than people like her
he cut off the side of her mind and as
he buried his face in the pillow he
caught a sight of the lady May
she has a cat he thought that's all she
is a cat
but that was not how his mind saw her
quick beyond all dreams of speed sharp
clever unbelievably graceful beautiful
wordless and undemanding
where would he ever find a woman who
could compare with her
so that is the end of the story the game
of rat and dragon and uh it's always
amazing to me to to read through it
again not least because cord weiner
Smith is is so excellent in
narrating and depicting emotions and
connections between people and in this
case people and and partners
um he's he's good at thinking outside of
the purely human
and uh I'll probably continue reading
this story
you know for the next however many years
I'm I'm still alive and it's a quite a a
great one so let's let's uh have a
little discussion if you'd like
um John the bomb I think got his answer
earlier on literal rats no not literal
rats there these creatures
something you know we don't know what
they are but they're out there in the
recesses of empty space and they appear
as rats to the cats they appear as
dragons to us human beings and the pin
lighters think of them in both ways
because the pin lighters share their
Consciousness their very being with
their Partners these telepathic cats
so lady thistle says just watch the
video on it last night on the the the
the the uh short story and now I can't
stop thinking about the rule of names as
I listen so the rule of names Ursula
Kayla greens uh one of her very early
Earthsea stories right
um that's that's uh quite a good one as
well there's a dragon involved in that
the one who has plundered uh Pender
right and
um a dragon that is in the form of Mr
Hunter Underhill so there is there is
actually a lexical connection between
the two stories yeah you know um
Le green
coordiner Smith they're both among some
of my
favorite uh writers and and in part
because of the extensiveness of the
humanity that
shines through their works I would say
um and you know uh cord weiner Smith
didn't manage to write more than one
novel uh and that's even a fairly short
novel but his his short stories that are
all collected here in this omnibus
the rediscovery of man are quite
wonderful as our Le guin's stories and
her novels as well so yeah what are uh
people who are watching what are your
thoughts about this story anything that
you want to bring up any questions that
you have about this or about cord weiner
Smith himself who uh was actually
forgetting his first name Linda Barger
uh was his his uh actual name uh he
wrote Under the pseudonym of cord weiner
Smith and there's you know a lot of
great stories in this instrumentality of
mankind narrative Universe which spans
um I would say hundreds of Millennia
perhaps I'd have to take a look at the
timeline in there and there's there's
all these great imaginative interactions
between human beings and
um the
other creatures that are created out of
a fusion of humans and animals and space
travel takes place in a number of
different stages requiring uh different
means to overcome the dangers of of
space in his works as well so but I'm
curious to see what other people make of
this uh this wonderful little short
story uh I've been as I said I've been
reading it myself since I was a kid
off and on and
I you know it's pretty short you notice
it took me about a little over half an
hour to read uh out loud you can read it
quicker
um
just letting your eyes do the work
but
um
it's very rich I would say it's very
rich and suggestive isn't it
so
um
I will have a little coffee and see if
anybody has anything that they want to
Say by means of response or question or
comment and then we'll
move on to that
in the meantime as people are writing
I'll say that so this is a new kind of
you know
video and event and I'm thinking I'll do
this as a regular thing like maybe once
a month or so uh picking other short
stories not necessarily science fiction
or even speculative fiction but perhaps
other short stories that I found
particularly enjoyable and meaningful
by a vast variety of authors you know
which might include people like Graham
Greene as well
um there's there's a short story of his
that I do have in mind
um
there's there's others that I remember
the titles of but I don't remember who
wrote them
stories that I read when I was a good
bit younger and then um
you know
um
have kept reading as as time has gone on
so
well I don't see any questions or
comments here so maybe we'll wrap this
up a little bit early
um you know we've got basically three
parts to this I tell you a little bit
about why I'm doing this story I read
the story and then it's uh whatever
interaction people want to have so
we'll give it one more
going once going twice going going three
times thing anybody
um
Cash America says love you Dr Sayler
been watching forever well that's very
nice of you to say yeah I I'm glad
you've you've been here you know
um there's a lot of uh
videos we've been doing a lot of
different kinds so English says why is
the story important I guess it depends
on what you think important is you know
you could say that
you know if you want to read card Wayne
or Smith's uh works and understand his
notion of like what space is like
something he gave a lot of thought to
and how we might reach out to the Stars
it could be important for that I kind of
think it's important because it's it's
such a
well thought out
um Imagination of what it could be like
for us to share
the space of Consciousness not just with
another person
but with another
connected mammal you know not not a
complete alien right and that's
something that would be so much more
foreign I think to us like you know an
octopus or an arachnid of some sort but
a cat you know what would it be like to
share our Consciousness with a cat and
what sort of you notice there's there's
a it I don't want to call it romantic
and I also don't want to call it erotic
but there is an intimacy
that is kind of analogous to what
happens with romantic partners that
um happens with these two characters
right the pin lighter and Lady May which
doesn't happen with Captain wah or the
other the other cats as well
um but you notice that he this has also
happened with him before when he was
caught cheating
um so I think you know being able to
depict these sort of things and put them
forward as something for us to imagine
makes it
we could call that important perhaps
right
but
you know it's not as if this is the only
way in which we could do that so it's
it's not a absolutely necessary means
for that
um it's merely a sufficient means I
think you could say so that's why I
think the story is important uh maybe
others have other views on that you know
um any other questions comments
people would like me to uh respond to
all right well I'm not I'm not seeing
any others so maybe we'll wrap this one
up
um I set aside an hour to to go over
this we can end a little bit early so
once again
um for anybody who is missed out on this
is coming from the rediscovery of man
the
um complete shorts uh science fiction
out here yeah the complete short science
fiction of cord Wayne or Smith I kept
expecting to see the word story in there
somewhere but
um it's not there great uh Anthology
that has a ton of of uh really wonderful
things uh this one is about a third of
the way through
um published originally 1956 and uh
titled the game of rat and dragon so we
will do another one of these next month
and I'll figure out which story I want
to do next maybe I'll even do a little
poll or something like that we'll see
but thanks for tuning in and if you
haven't read this this story I so
recommend checking it out it's very
short there's a link in the video
description where you can go to Project
Gutenberg and uh easily uh read it there
it's got some great illustrations as
well which is kind of cool if you want
to get the cord wiener Smith book you
there's also a link for that and if you
do
purchase that and start reading your way
through it I think you will be very
pleasantly
surprised by the incredible range of his
his writing and his thoughts so all
right I will see you and until next time
um
you know keep on reading and enjoying
all this great fiction that we have
nowadays at our fingertips
foreign